>> President Trump: THANK YOU
AS WELL TO OUR DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN FOR BEING
HERE.
FLEW DOWN TOGETHER.
PRESS WANTS TO KNOW, WHY DIDN'T
YOU TALK ABOUT IT?
WE HAD A VERY GOOD TALKER, I
WILL SAY.
IT BECAME A VERY BIG STORY
ACTUALLY, FOLKS.
WE HAD A GOOD TALK.
>> Laura: BOY DID THAT KEEP
PEOPLE GUESSING.
THAT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP
SURPRISING A LOT OF FOLKS WITH
HIS NEW FOUND SUPPORT FOR DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN.
THE MAN OVERSEEING THE ROBERT RB
THE MAN OVERSEEING THE ROBERT RR
THE MAN OVERSEEING THE ROBERT RT
MUELLER PROBE.
DEVON NUNEZ IS HERE TONIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS ON THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL TODAY?
THAT WAS KIND OF INTERESTING.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK ANY OF US
THINK THAT ROSENSTEIN SHOULD BE
DISMISSED BEFORE THE ELECTION.
I THINK HE DOES HAVE TO COME IN
THIS WEEK AND ANSWER WHETHER OR
NOT HE WAS WILLING TO WEAR A
CHOIR OR NOT AND WHETHER OR NOT
HE WAS LOOKING AT INVOKING THE
25TH AMENDMENT.
THOSE ARE KEY QUESTIONS THAT HE
WILL ANSWER BEFORE THE RUSSIA
TASK FORCE THIS WEEK SUPPOSEDLY
ON THURSDAY.
>> Laura: THE ISSUE OF THIS
REDACTED SERIES OF DOCUMENTS
REGARDING THE RUSSIA PROBE,
PEOPLE WATCHING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, SAYING OKAY, YOU GUYS
ARE ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT THIS.
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE DECLASSIFIED
OR THEY ARE NOT WERE PARTIALLY
DECLASSIFIED.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH
A FEW OTHERS FROM THE INTEL
COMMUNITY CONVINCED THE
PRESIDENT, CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG, NOT TO DECLASSIFY
DOCUMENTS ABOUT THE FIRES OUT
WARRANT AGAINST CARTER PAGE AND
OTHERS.
AND IT KICKED IT OVER TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
CORRECT?
WHAT ELSE DO WE KNOW ABOUT THIS?
>> THAT'S CORRECT AND THAT'S
REALLY MY BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE FBI.
EVERY TIME I TRY TO GET
SOMETHING OUT OF THE PUBLIC,
THEY CRY WOLF.
THE PRESIDENT WAS VERY CLEAR AND
SAID THAT THESE DOCUMENTS NEED
TO BE IMMEDIATELY DECLASSIFIED,
WITHOUT REDUCTIONS.
THEN SUDDENLY, THE IG WAS
BROUGHT IN.
NOW MY CHALLENGE WITH AGAINST
THE IG, THE IDEA IS PROBABLY A
GREAT GUY BUT WE ARE CONGRESS
AND WE BELIEVE PEOPLE HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW THIS INFORMATION.
IT NEEDS TO BE MADE PUBLIC, NOT
MUCH INFORMATION.
BUT WE WANT THE PRESIDENT TO BE
CLASSIFIED AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
MENTIONED HE WOULD.
SO IT'S NOW BEEN TWO AND A HALF
OR THREE WEEKS AND IT DOESN'T
TAKE THAT LONG.
YOU ARE ONLY TALKING ABOUT 20
PAGES OF FISA AND I THINK ABOUT
A DOZEN OR SO OTHER REPORTS, AN
AND, I JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY
ARE THINKING HERE.
THE PRESIDENT I THINK IT IS A
SMART GUY, AND I THINK HE NEEDS
TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT WHO HE
LISTENS TO.
>> Laura: WHILE ADAM SCHIFF IS
ALL OVER THIS AS YOU MIGHT
IMAGINE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THE SINGLE ACT OF USING A
NEVER BEFORE HOUSE RULE TO
SELECTIVELY RELEASE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION IN THE NOW NUNEZ
MEMORANDUM, AND IT WAS A
FRAUDULENT ONE AT THAT.
>> HE'S HONESTLY NOT TALKING
ABOUT A PARTICULAR ISSUE BUT,
BUT MAKING A PERSONAL ABOUT YOU,
YOU KNOW YOU ARE USED TO THIS
AND RUNNING FOR REELECTION, AND
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO MAKE
YOU OUT BE    TO BE THE BOGEYMAN
YOU OUT BE    TO BE THE BOGEYMAH
YOU OUT BE    TO BE THE BOGEYMAR
YOU OUT BE    TO BE THE BOGEYMAE
BUT AT THIS POINT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT AMERICANS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED AND WHY AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN WAS SPIED UPON
USING DOCUMENTS THAT WE ARE
CREATED AT THE FUNDING OF THE
PRESIDENT'S OPPONENTS DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.
>> THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND THE FRIENDS OF THE MEDIA
WHICH IS PRETTY MUCH ALL OF
THEM, EXCEPT FOR 10%, AND ALL
THE BAD PEOPLE FROM THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION WERE FUMBLING
THIS STUFF IN THE FBI.
THEY HAVE A DOZEN PEOPLE IN THE
FBI AND DOJ THAT ARE GONE.
WE HAD TO MAKE SURE THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC KNEW THAT THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT SOMEBODY
WAS DOING TO BASICALLY SET UP A
CAMPAIGN AND ACCUSE THEM OF
POLLUTING WITH RUSSIANS WAS
REALLY WRONG.
WE ARE PROVING THAT ONLY
COLLISION THAT HAPPENED WAS
COLLISION WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
IN THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE
RUSSIANS.
AND I WILL TELL YOU, I STILL
WANT TO KNOW WHY NOBODY IS
INVESTIGATING WHAT RUSSIANS
WERE, AND THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN WERE TALKING TO
THROUGH FUSION GPS AND FEEDING
THAT INFORMATION INTO THE FBI.
NOW WE KNOW THAT BROKE LAST WEEK
AND YOU KIND OF ALLUDED TO IT
EARLIER, AND, I'M SORRY, BUT
THAT DOESN'T SMELL GOOD TO ME.
>> YOU CAN'T BE HAVING
POLITICAL -- ARE MEETINGS THAT
EVEN HAVE THE APPEARANCE OF